le nombre des jours de maladie des
assurés sociaux pèsent très lourdement
sur le budget de la sécurité sociale les
arrêts maladie coûte trop cher un
refrain entendu depuis au moins 40 ans
et pourtant il y en a eu des mesures
déjà dans les années 70 les médecins
trop complaisant sont dans le viseur une
commission existe elle doit demander des
explications voire rappeler à l'ordre
les médecins dont le profil s'éloigne
trop de la moyenne ce qui délivre trop
facilement des arrêts de travail par
exemple
théoriquement les médecins fautif risque
le déconventionnement autre source
d'économies faire la chasse aux faux
malades qui abuseraient du système selon
les autorités alors dans les années 70
des sociétés privées de médecins
contrôleurs sont créés une activité
lucrative pour certaines sociétés
privées de médecin contrôleur plusieurs
entreprises comme peugeot à dijon font
appel à leurs services
malgré cet attirail même rengaine dans
les années 2000
il ya par département deux trois
médecins
pas plus qu'ils abusent et qui finissent
par être spécialisé dans les arrêts
maladie est bien pour cela nous avons
décidé que l'on pourrait suspendre leur
possibilité de prescrire
dm des arrêts maladie en 2009
l'idée du gouvernement c'est d'instaurer
le télétravail pendant les congés
maladie dans un congé maladie vous
pouvez parfaitement être handicapé et
maintenu à votre domicile sans pour
autant
avoir perdu ni vos facultés
intellectuelles ni votre énergie
en 2011 les salariés gagnant plus de
2500 euros bruts voient leurs indemnités
journalières réduite 2016 la sécurité
sociale préconise des barèmes pour
chaque arrêt cinq jours d'arrêt pour une
grippe
trois jours pour une angine et enfin raw
dossiers en 2010 est le retour du jour
de carence pour les fonctionnaires en
arrêt de travail il avait été instauré
souvenez vous par nicolas sarkozy puis
supprimé par françois hollande
il sera donc très tôt malgré toutes ces
mesures successives la facture des
arrêts de travail a augmenté de 13,4
pour cent entre 2013 et 2016 selon un
rapport de l'assurance maladie en 2005
cette entreprise alsacienne avait
peut-être la solution isolation phonique
protection thermique et postes de
travail optimisé dans de nouveaux locaux
ont divisé ici l'absentéisme par deux le
confort au travail réel investissement
productif à terme c'est déjà une
tradition dans d'autres pays et une
nouvelle évidence en france
[Musique]